hey this is Jessica Biel and I'm going
undercover on the Internet it's actually
me Instagram is it still strange to see
your face on a billboard yes I think it
is still a little bit strange it's also
completely normal which is strange it's
weird it's big what are the chances we
will ever see a seventh heaven reboot
I'm currently watching it on Amazon such
a great show it's so nice thank you it
was a great show I don't know about a
seventh heaven reboot genuinely I've
heard some talks about it I don't really
know how real it is to be honest but yes
possible posted is acting still your
first love compared to producing or even
writing that's such a good question
actually I think so your interests kind
of evolve and change as you get older
and I still love it absolutely but I'm
definitely feeling the pull of being
behind the camera a lot more of these
days so it is still currently but I'm
enjoying doing both of those things or
all three of those things and probably
hope to do more of the producing in the
writing in the future ad Jessica Biel
how come no sinner this year we couldn't
really find a way that felt authentic to
to bring Cora back into that story we
thought of everything I mean would she
be Bill Pullman you know Harry Ambrose
the character the detective would could
she be his sort of sidekick and could
they investigate together
could she be his expert on mental health
issues can can her experience help him
on to understand the mind or the
behaviors of someone who has possibly
committed a crime and we thought of
everything could they could there be a
love interest thing like what can we do
here that that really feels like you'd
want to see this story continue and
nothing
felt right everything felt forced and it
felt stronger to just leave it alone and
end it there I mean it's possible that
you could meet up with her again I guess
in another season because every season
is such a one-off story but I don't know
I don't know if I don't know if we're
gonna go in that direction posted how is
it juggling family and business when you
and hubby are both in the entertainment
fields
I think juggling family in business no
matter what field you're in is hard
always a challenge for anybody trying to
work and trying to have a family and
find that balance between it all and you
entertainment field it's kind of a
double-edged sword because your partner
really understands what you're doing and
really understands the time requirements
and how weird it is and strange things
that have to happen and how much time
you have to spend away and you know you
really understand that as well for your
partner but it's hard because since
you're both in the business you can both
be gone at the same time you know it
would almost sometimes it's like is it
easier if someone just has a very more
traditional job and then someone else is
kind of doing crazy stuff when you're
both doing unorthodox things it can be
really hard sometimes you just never see
each other so it can be it can be really
good and it can be you know a real
challenge at the same time posted
Wikipedia
while growing up beal played soccer and
trained as a level six gymnast true i
think you can start competing as a level
five gymnast so it was just about to be
competing I think in level six
that's like roundoff back handspring
you're on the vaults you're not flipping
on the vault yet you're doing cartwheels
on the beam you're just kind of getting
into a much more difficult set of tricks
and your routines are gonna be more
complex so I was like not really there
yet but almost there I am Divi collects
vintage glasses with no lenses yes okay
that was true a long time ago when I was
I think are on 14 or something I was
working in Vancouver at the time and I
gotta say I thought I was pretty cool
wearing those glasses no lenses like no
lenses at all you know you get older and
you learn stuff that wasn't so cool I
don't think audition for a role in
American Beauty 1999 not true actually
I've heard this before
I mean unless I have literally like a
blackout time in my life with which is
possible I do not believe that I
auditioned for a role in American Beauty
submit her first acting job was in a
Pringles commercial when she was 11
years old I think that's definitely true
I think 11 and was it the first I think
it was I think that's pretty true I
think my parents were originally going
to name me snowmobile so I guess in that
respect Jessica was a real win for me
that was always obviously not 100% real
but they my parents they would just mess
with my brother and I and you know and
say yeah we could have named you snow mo
anata mo so you should you should feel
lucky about your lives because yeah that
would have been a real disaster I think
you go through life with snow mower
autumn Oh Twitter
Jessica Biel never got credit for being
a beast look at her arms and blade
Trinity how is she not Laura Croft or
Electra if you're gonna cast a white
woman where was Jessica Biel's action
career I am mad about this thank you so
much for all of that that is that makes
me feel great
you know a good question I don't know
I'm not 100% sure if I wanted an action
career more than I already had one a
kind of pick I really kind of was able
to do a couple of films like that which
which was really fun these arms are
ridiculous they are humongous and too
big genuinely speaking they're
terrifying looking yeah ask me your
career just goes in a certain way and
thank goodness my arms have deflated
since then nice look is the bag so that
you don't get food out the outfit
underneath it's actually fashion did you
know that the first time Jessica Biel
gave someone an autograph she asked for
what in return I did do that I believe I
was so embarrassed I just got I just got
embarrassed and I was like can I have
yours you know yeah I just felt really
shy about it
okay now that I'm done with Handmaid's
Tale I don't know what to do with myself
dying for season 3 but what show should
I get into next my mom is recommending
the center with Jessica Biel thoughts I
think I responded to Kim Kim I think I
responded to you and said absolutely do
it I think she watched it I feel like
maybe she watched it and commented on it
anyway I hope you liked it
next please help me what kind of
workouts are weightlifting should I do
to get arms like hers the arm thing guys
number one it's kind of a genetic thing
my mom has arms like this my dad my
brother and then just a lot of hard work
a lot of circuit training a lot of yoga
and a lot of Pilates and you can do it
but don't let him get that big okay
that's too big did I just offend the
fitness world like the real serious
fitness world by saying that I hope not
no offense meant
it's just too big for me Cora Cora what
is that
Cora who's making me feel really old
Cora okay what's the most embarrassing
thing that jessica biel has done I
probably can't I can't think of the most
embarrassing thing but I probably can't
share it with you because it was so
embarrassing
I don't want to relive it how does the
acting differ when a person is both the
lead actor the slash actress and
producer like Jessica Biel well you sort
of have to wear two hats obviously and
you have to split your time when you're
on set but also focus when you're
working as an actor that day and not
worry about the my new show not worry
about the budget not worry about what's
going on with that crew member and not
worry about the location that we lost
you know all of these things that
producers do and have to really pay
attention to and work out problems
they're basically problem solvers and
fire putter outers but how it also
differs is when you're producing it a
show or a film or whatever you can
really develop the character from the
beginning with the writer you can be a
part of the the whole process you can
have a voice in it and that for me from
a creative standpoint is the most
exciting part of the puzzle doing all
your research as the character while
you're developing it so the second you
step on set you feel like you've already
been standing in the shoes of this
person and it's a much smoother
transition because usually I feel like
when you're doing a show or a film by
the time you've gotten to about the last
week of filming you go oh now I
understand who this person is because
you've finally been living it for so
long but if you can live it before you
actually step on set then it's alive for
you in a much different way how did
Justin Timberlake and Jessica Biel meet
we really technically met and had a
conversation
when I was invited to a birthday party
that Justin was throwing for a friend of
his and met him at that birthday party
submit thank you guys thank you internet
for all of your questions and your
interest in me in my personal life see
you soon